okay it's just preparing
my screen says we're live and streaming
yes now you are live and i'm going to
mute myself and turn it over
to you good morning morning and welcome
to
house finance as vice chairman of the
house finance committee i find that due
to the state of emergency declared by
the governor
as a result of the coven 19 pandemic and
in accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
2020-04 this public body is authorized
to meet electronically
this is a public hearing of bills
referred to the finance committee
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting however in accordance with the
emergency order
i am confirming that all members of the
committee and select legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform
or by telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91-8
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should be me
ledge.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
lba staff are on the meeting and
assisting us
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote however
these are all public hearings we do not
expect to be taking any votes today
we will start the meeting by taking a
roll call attendance
when each member states their present
please
also state whether there's anyone in the
room with you during this meeting
which is required by the right to know
law would the clerk
[Music]
representative okay all right we got it
can you all hear me
yep you're not muted we can hear you
well it's supposed to work off the space
bar but i guess
technical difficulties all right
representative ober i'm president i'm in
my home my husband's upstairs on a ways
and means zoom call meeting
i hope the cats answer with him
representative umberger
uh here i'm in my home
my husband is here not listening
but he is in the house representative
danielson
dennis is absent
madison representative petry
i am here at home my wife is wandering
around the halls and the dog
is also wandering around the halls in
farmington
representative emrick i am alone in my
home office in hampton
representative president alone in my
home office
representative griffin i'm a home
i'm home alone in my office
representative edwards
he just called me he he's in the
building over
over at the legislative office building
looking for the rest of us
all right no marking is absent for that
for now
representative bean i'm present i'm in
guilford in my home
i'm president i'm in my home in concord
and my husband's in the house
organ
i'm here in hanover alone in my dining
room
very good nice to hear from you
representative bucco
i'm present i'm at home in conway and
representative leishman good morning joe
uh
i'm here in peterborough alone at my
house in
peterborough nice to see you
representative rogers i'm here in
concord
representative walls i'm here my husband
and my daughter are elsewhere in the
house but i'm alone in this part of the
house
representative keith good morning um
mary heath i'm here in manchester and
i'm home
and my husband's in the other room
representative murray
good morning i'm here in newcastle i'm
in my office my husband is in the
another part of the house and the dog is
trotting around
thank you very much and representative
wyler
kingston i'm alone in this room there
are others in the house
okay we have a quorum we don't need a
quorum but that's your roll call
i'm going to open the meeting the public
hearing on
hb 297 i would ask members
please keep yourself muted so that we
can cut down on the extraneous noise
raise your hand using the raise your
hand feature if you wish to ask
a question and i will recognize
representative ken weiler chairman of
finance and prime sponsor
of the bill good morning representative
weiler
good morning madam chair and good
morning members of the committee
i will first begin with reading a letter
from alan and
susan mcelveen dear committee members
were here today on behalf of all victims
of frm
and to talk about not what vrm did
but what the new hampshire banking
department and attorney general's office
did not do concerning frm just as the
person who allows a drug abuser to
continue
using is an enabler the banking
department and attorney general office
were enablers to frm
frm read their inaction to enforce the
law as a green light to continue their
criminal behavior costing hundreds of
families their life savings
and in two instances their lives banking
department licensed
and audited frm from 2000 to 2009.
it documented 79 violations of state and
federal law
insolvency and received at least 15
complaints
no enforcement actions were taken the
banking commit
commissioner's two brothers were both
preferred stockholders
of frm the attorney general's office
responsible for both criminal law
and consumer protection law received at
least seven complaints
including two from a former new
hampshire assistant attorney general
no enforcement actions were taken and
the complaints were passed on to the
banking department
the chandler's report in 2011
concluded that mistakes were made in the
frm matter
including those mistakes that rose to
the level of failure of state government
the state had the necessary tools and
resources at its disposal
to perform their statutory duty and
adequately protect the consumer
but failed to do so when needed to reach
out and take responsible action
agencies of the state with direct
oversight responsibility
became timid and hid behind
technicalities
and failed to exercise their full
statutory authority
governor hassan signed into law in 2013
the general court hereby finds that
there has been documented evidence
that certain state agencies made
mistakes knowingly or
unknowingly that resulted in the
continuance of the financial resource
mortgage frm
fraud causing financial harm to many
victims
written into this law is the formula to
determine the amount of restitution
which is 50 of their net loss for each
eligible claimant
in summary is total amount of mortgage
loan to third parties from 2006 to 2009
minus repayment of any loan or retained
ownership of any loan
minus all interest paid on all loans
excuse me minus amounts paid to u.s
bankruptcy
trustees minus mortgage amounts
forfeited to u.s
bank bankruptcy excuse me
minus recoveries paid by the u.s
bankruptcy trustee
minus recoveries from other sources some
divided by two equals mass maximum
restitution amount it's important to
emphasize the formula only provides
recovery assistance at the rate of 50
cents
on each dollar or 50 percent of net loss
and frmb been shut down no later than
may 2006 as mary jordan
director of consumer credit banking
department testified before the governor
and executive
board at commissioner peter hildreth's
removal hearing
we wouldn't be here this bill would not
be before you
but we are here because frm was never
shut down and we are sincerely asking
for your support
that's alan susan mclevene now i have my
own
testimony i chaired a study committee on
the frm
scandal in 2012. it was a follow-on to a
joint house and senate commerce
committee
held a year or two before subsequent to
that
the secretary of state bill gardner had
engaged
attorney charles chandler to do an
investigation
he felt that the attorney general in the
banking department were trying to shift
the blame for the problem
onto the securities department which
comes under the secretary of state
in order to protect the governor
chandler had interviewed about 200
people
and it put everyone under oath gartner
showed me the minutes from both studies
assistant attorney general head had
given one answer under oath
and the opposite to the study committee
banking commissioner hildreth
had not acted as the new law re as the
law required
while he and his brother were collecting
interest payments in their frm
investments as high as 16 interest
he was the one who tried to say the frm
matter was a securities responsibility
the members of my study committee were
convinced from the 12 meetings that we
held
that the attorney general and the
banking department were colluding
in an attempt to blame securities
department and cover up
their own shortcomings and possible
illegal actions
as a result of chandler's investigation
the governor and council held a
termination hearing
for commissioner hildreth a very
thorough lawyer who was presenting the
case against hildren
of hildreth hildreth turned to the
governor governor lynch and said
i'm not going down alone the governor
called a recess for lunch
two hours later they reconvened and the
governor announced
that the hearing was ended and hildreth
had taken retirement
i hope that you have heard enough to see
that the investors
who did their due diligence and made
inquiries of the attorney general and
the banking department
were lied to and misled banking had a
list of 79 violations through the years
of operation
many of which should have disqualified
frm from operating
the attorney had an active investigation
against farah for telling his client
skillmate or the attorney general rather
and an act of investigation against
farrah
the head of frm for telling his client
skillman
that the funds that he had been given to
invest for her had all been lost
both agencies should have been punished
for their failures and cover-up
both agencies answered inquiries as if
our government did serious damage to
people's life savings
got 10 million in last term's budget to
give a fraction of losses to the frm
budgets
but the whole situation was
mischaracterized by legislators who
defeated it
we need to make amendments for the
government's shortcomings where else can
citizens go for justice
when the case was sent to the bankruptcy
court the trustee saw a chance to enrich
himself
by eight million dollars and the victims
felt that they had been victimized all
over again
please fund this bill the mechanism has
been in place
for you i thank you happy to answer any
questions
thank you for your testimony
representative weiler do any committee
members have
representative looks like you convinced
us with your testimony
we appreciate your effort we appreciate
your good testimony and thank you for
testifying this morning
some there's some some speaking going on
i couldn't hear
i i think that might have been uh why
yeah
i'm i'm representative norman silber i'm
from belknap district 2
which are the towns of meredith and
guilford meredith was the epicenter of
this fraud
and the whole lakes region as well as
other parts of the state
saw lots of their citizens suffer as a
result of this fraud it was the biggest
financial fraud in the history of new
hampshire
estimated to be a losses of about 80
million dollars
i think it's important to look back and
see
who lost money were these investors
sophisticated investors the clear answer
is no
they were the average mom and pop who
thought that they were solicited
to make safe investments and when they
checked with the government agencies in
new hampshire
who were responsible for regulating frm
they were
constantly assured and reassured that
this was a legitimate
uh honest enterprise and that their
investments would probably be just fine
as it turned out that was not the case
so we had basically three
departments involved in this oversight
of this
uh its operation that turned out to be a
fraud
the banking department the bureau of
securities regulation and the attorney
general's office
to characterize any of them or each of
them
as toothless tigers would be an insult
to tigers they either through
incompetence inattention negligence
or collusion allow this fraud to go on
for many many years to the detriment of
lots of our citizens
these people lost lots of money in many
cases their life savings
the citizens of our state i believe have
a right to rely
on regulations of highly regulated
industries such as frm
if if you're investing money and putting
money into a highly regulated state
regulated
agency uh enterprise i think it's
reasonable
to assume that these agencies are doing
their jobs
and these agencies were not doing their
jobs
so basically a lot of people lost their
money
some people were able to only as far as
i know only one person went to jail
one person was permitted to take a
retirement probably getting a retirement
pension to to this day there were
all sorts of allegations of collusion
family relationships leading to some of
the highest
officers and officials in the state
so this is a really a black stain on new
hampshire's
financial history and on the history of
new hampshire government
the the bill seeks 10 million dollars
which will not make people whole
it will give them a little bit of
something the legislature passed
the statute establishing this recovery
fund which of course has never been
funded
and this is an effort to fund that i
have a suggestion of where can we get
the 10 million dollars
let's take it from the budgets of the
banking department and the bureau of
securities regulation
and the attorney general's office
because they clearly
do not know how to utilize their funding
properly thank you
thank you for your testimony
representative silber does the committee
have any questions for the
representative this morning
if so please indicate by raising your
you're muted ma'am
come on sorry um
representative silver are you aware that
there are generally about
10 ponzi schemes a month discovered in
this country and in the last 10 years
there have been 600
ponzi schemes similar to the fm ponzi
scheme
that have been discovered in the united
states no i'm not aware of those numbers
and are you aware of any time in any
ponzi scheme
anywhere that they have used taxpayer
dollars
to reimburse the victims of the ponzi
scheme i am not aware of that no
well neither am i and as far as i know
none of the 600 in the last decade or
the hundreds before that have ever used
taxpayer dollars
yes mike my question is um
is this as sponsor
is this the only time that you're going
to ask for money
or is this just the beginning of
uh requesting money from
the um the state i believe this is the
only time i'm not aware of any
plans for any subsequent requests
the the legislation establishing the
recovery fund limits the recovery
to 50 cents on the dollar i don't think
this 10 million dollars will even cover
50 cents on the dollar
but i do i'm not aware of any subsequent
any plans for any subsequent requests
if if let me just add if this
uh operation the frm had been audited
as opposed to being audited by the state
agencies had been audited by a reputable
cpa firm
and the the cpa firm did not catch the
fraud
the cpa firm would have been sued in a
class action on behalf of all the
investors
their insurance would have come forth
with a payment far in excess probably
closer to
you know 80 90 cents maybe even 100
cents on the dollar but this is not
that's not the case that would they were
not audited by far as i know by a
reputable cpa firm they were supposedly
audited by our state agencies
uh no that's fine thank you thank you
representative leishman you have your
representative ober can you hear me this
is mike hoffman
um i believe we have representative
edwards who shows up on your screen as
house finance he's waving to us now
can you change his name please to say
representative edwards
yes i can give that a try he's he's
always why is he a co-host
he he actually has mike kane's
phone i think uh or login right now
that's why representative leishman are
you unfrozen
i believe so madam chair all right you
were you were next followed by
representative hatch
thanks madam chair and uh thanks for
your testimony sir
uh there were a number of court cases
involving this uh
if you will scandal have all of them
been settled or dispensed with
or you know the status i do not know the
status
i'm sorry thanks thanks madam chair
you're welcome representative hatch you
were next
thank you thank you madam chair thank
you for taking my question
and thanks for the testimony and i think
part of my query and concern was just
brought out by the fact that
uh the last testifier stated that had
there been a reputable cpr audit firm
to go through the books of this firm
um the and allowed to exist and go on
they would have been held liable now
that goes back
to my um thought that i've heard several
times
how everybody did their due diligence
i'm sorry you're you're taking a risk
when you invest something and part of
that risk to mitigate it are
part of what you need to do to mitigate
that risk is take a deep dive
into what's going on within a firm and i
have to say
i don't think anybody really
exhibited in my mind anyways
due diligence because that in fact
as just stated was not done
now many of us at this table
representative
many of us aren't sophisticated
investors
but i'll tell you what um before i
invest
that's part of what i do so i i just i'm
sorry i just need to
answer or hear
what else was done in terms of due
diligence were profiles looked at
by clients what was going on clients
looked at
et cetera thank you madam chair what was
done as far as due diligence was
they the investors many times contacted
these different state agencies
to either inquire or to raise complaints
and they were constantly reassured
that everything was okay with them and
there's a long history going back
many years over the course of this fraud
that they did contact state agencies
that was the only way that they could do
due diligence was to contact the state
agencies because they were
investing in a company that was
supposedly in a highly regulated
industry
you have a follow-up question
representative hatch well
i i again i i think my question wasn't
answered
i asked um did the people look at the
profiles of the clients
and and let me put this in perspective
there there are a lot of
investment opportunities that aren't
insured by the fdic
that are similar to what happened here
in this ponzi scheme
that are legitimate i had a minor in a
minor way participate in one
but the information i needed to do my
due diligence
was available and had it not been
available
had i looked at this similar
circumstance
um i don't believe i would have been
doing my due diligence
and that's a bad on me not a bad on the
state
and again to just rely on a state agency
alone
tells me that that wasn't done if there
was suspicion there
there were other venues other things
that needed to be done
by the investors to protect themselves
when you invest
you have to protect yourself
and that wasn't done thank you madam
chair all right i can't hear where that
was done
like and i'm sorry to take up so much
time but i think this is important
i asked what were some of the clients
profiles
people that invest in something like
that get that information
before they invest and i haven't heard
from one person
and all the testimonies and i feel bad
for these people
but i haven't heard from one that this
activity took place
and so i'm sorry investor beware thank
you madam chair
representative silber i'm not sure there
was a question in there but
if there was do you wish to respond i
didn't i didn't hear a question either
the question was what was the profile of
the
different people that uh borrowed these
funds that's part of due diligence
what were their ficas what were their
history uh what was what was a payment
schedule by this company
uh when i invested in has a less than
one percent default rate
having uh having experienced personally
in my family
my father lost money in a mortgage fraud
not frm but in another mortgage fraud
scheme
and i also represented a a judge who
lost money in a mortgage fraud scheme
these things happen with some degree of
regularity
and it's usually people who are not very
sophisticated
uh they don't they rely upon the state
regulators
and each of these in each of those cases
the mortgage companies with whom they
place their money as
investments were in a highly regulated
industry by the state
and they relied on the state regulation
and auditing
process to make sure that these these
operations were being run
legitimately and were not frauds and
they completely in this case
representative edwards you're hiding i
guess as representative
as uh michael caine you have your hand
up
i i do um we're test driving the room
can you hear me
we can always hear you if you're unmuted
representative
okay so can you hear me now
one two three one question
representative
can you hear me you've been called on to
testify representative
can you okay so i can't tell if you can
hear me but
um i'll go ahead edwards just in case
you don't know when you're unmuted we
can hear you so we've been hearing you
i don't know how mute and unmute work on
this microphone madam chair
so that's why i was asking i'm going to
assume you can hear me and this is
uh i have a question and a follow-up
the question uh stipulates for the
purpose of the question
that the investors relied
materially upon the attestations
of senior government employees
that the fund was legitimate so so with
that
context uh representative silber
um i want to ask you about sovereign
immunity if
if our state actors had been merely
incompetent
would we have a reasonable
argument to rely on sovereign immunity
to save the taxpayer the 10 million
dollars
thank you for the question
representative edwards i don't know the
answer to that
i've never explored the concept of
sovereign immunity in the case of this
egregious fraud
okay may i ask a follow-up man i'm sure
yes follow-up
uh and then uh on the other side of the
coin
would the ethics of the state relying on
sovereign immunity
shift if it were
believed that the senior state actors
had intentionally acted in a corrupt
manner
and intentionally misled the public
would would the ethics
of relying on sovereign immunity shift
to where it would be unethical to hide
behind that shield
thank you for the question i think from
a
looking at it from a moralistic and a
philosophical perspective
of course the ethics would shift but i
don't think that
in sovereign immunity ethics plays much
of a role
i think that either there's sovereign
immunity or there's not i haven't
explored the case law in a situation
like this
but the the actions that i've read about
and and have done the research on as far
as what took place
by these departments involved and we're
so egregious that
to hide behind the shield of sovereign
immunity if that's what they want to try
to
play that card is is an insult to this
to the taxpayers
thank you for your answers thank you
madam chair
see no other hands-raised representative
silver i'd like to thank you for your
testimony and for taking questions
thank you very much i'm off to judiciary
thank you you're welcome
no one else has signed up to speak is
there anybody else who wishes to speak
and mr hoffman i can't see the attendees
so you will have to
provide a little assistance here we have
madame chair this is nancy lavines we
have tom donovan
from the new hampshire attorney
general's office who wishes to speak
can you bring him forward for me nancy
yes
are you there he's there he needs to
unmute himself
can you unmute yourself mr donovan
yes hi and uh can people hear me
yes okay um when you're muted
believe me we hear you your dog
everybody else
great hi this is tom donovan i'm the
director of
charitable trust at the attorney
general's office and thank you members
of the committee for allowing me to
speak today
um the attorney general's office is not
taking a position on this bill one way
or the other
um but my position the director of
charitable trust
is named in the underlying statute
to appoint a
a person to administer the fund it's
it would be my responsibility to hire
the person
and to provide supervision in that
regard so i have some familiarity with
it
um this uh statute
rsa 359 p
passed in 2016 and pursuant to that i
went out
and tried to find an administrator
i advertised in business and legal
publications
got a couple of nibbles uh interviewed a
couple of people and i thought i had one
person on the hook
in the end that person declined
because part of the responsibility of
the administrator was
to refine the money to raise the money
that that administrator would then use
uh to
distribute in accordance with the
formula in the statute
um and then the administrator would only
be paid no more than 10 percent of
whatever
he or she was able to raise that
financial arrangement
was not appetizing um
to anyone and so that was the end of it
um so i i understand again not taking
position that this is an attempt to
provide the funding
um that perhaps would make it uh more
attractive to
find an administrator who would be
compensated from the fund
i want to point out though that there is
a section in the current statute
that says the administrator can only be
compensated from
private dollars that go into the fund
if the if the legislature makes an
appropriation that's public dollars
so that doesn't solve the problem
of uh finding money um that the
that the administrator from which the
legislator
sure could be paid so you need to
address that
um i i believe the other issue
uh is and um i think
uh representative umberger asked a
question if there were any other
legislation relating to uh finding
uh money for this fund i note that sb
127 that's one of those omnibus bills
over in the senate
has a provision that the fund
would be um uh
compensated would receive up to five
hundred thousand
dollars a year from the investors
education fund
which i think is a fund that um comes
from
fines that the uh securities bureau
wages uh raises um and so
that's an alternative and you you have
to think about
how these two bills would um
uh marry up to each other so those are
those are my only comments
and and i cannot speak if in case people
have questions about
the underlying um unfortunate
circumstances with the investors i i
can't speak to that i
wasn't at the attorney general's office
i'm in charitable trust we are not
involved with
uh securities or consumer protection we
we've we're in our own niche and
um um somehow
uh our our bureau was uh tasked to
to deal with the administrator so i
can't i can't answer the specifics of
on on any of that stuff but happy to
answer any other questions
mr donovan thank you for testifying this
morning i was in finance in 2016 when
that bill passed
we were told at the time and i know you
weren't in the
hearings when we had it but we were told
at the time that the bill sponsors
who were no longer in the legislature
had
private dollars ready to step forward to
fill that fund
which of course as you just testified
did not happen so we passed that
legislation in good faith
and thank you for reminding us that
the payment is only from private dollars
i appreciate that i was aware
of the bill in the senate so i
appreciate your
coming forward and updating everybody on
those things
does anybody have a question in any area
that mr donovan could respond to you
heard what he said where he can respond
where he cannot
any questions from the committee for
that
mr donovan i don't see any again thank
you for coming
forward and testifying this morning we
appreciate it okay
bye-bye bye does anybody else who is
attending wish to
to speak at this time who has not signed
up and again nancy
i need you to help me i think i see a
hand from somebody
uh glenn aldrich madam
would you please move representative
mr aldrich representative
you wish to testify
you have to unmute yourself sir i'm
sorry uh
whatever happened they kicked me back
off and we had to get re-uh situated
here but yes
uh can you hear your life representative
i'm sorry you're live you've been
recognized to testify
thank you very much uh there's not
really much i could add uh
the uh mcilvaneys uh
touched on everything representative
wyler touched on everything
i just wanted to get in here and throw
my support in i think the
state is culpable uh for
their uh what i consider lack of due
diligence
and uh the only other thing that i have
i heard somebody i think it was
uh representative walls asked if there
was any other taxpayer
money paying these schemes but i have a
question she may be able to ask
is the any other states involved in the
continuation of the fraud
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions for representative aldrich
seeing none thank you for your testimony
representative
thank you i see no other hands up
i will say that on the blue sheet
senator avard who also sent in written
testimony signed in in support
richard demark signed in in report
in support eric rathborn signed in in
support
however alexandria manila signed in
opposing
and jan schmidt signed in opposing
those are the only people who signed in
for
at this time seeing no other people
wanting to testify
i will close the public hearing on this
bill
the time being 9 39 chairman weiler we
have actually moved into the time for
the next bill which you are not a prime
sponsor of
uh thank you representative ober good
job um
we got through that fairly well all
right then we
i will now open the hearing on house
bill
398 and we'll call on the prime sponsor
representative bucco introduce the bill
thank you mr chairman for the record my
name is tom bucco and i
am one of three representatives from
carroll county district two
i appear today to introduce house bill
and to request that the finance
committee recommend this bill ought to
pass
house bill 398 makes appropriations to
the department of environmental services
for funding eligible wastewater projects
the appropriations in this bill include
operating budget
additional prioritized needs for fiscal
year
2022 and fiscal year 2023
plus state aid grant hopeful projects
for fiscal year 22 and fiscal year 23.
the title hopeful implies that the
municipality is hopeful
that funding will be available when the
municipality must begin repaying its
bonded debt
the projects in the sag hopeful project
list are listed by the year that their
first repayments will be due
for fiscal year 22 the prioritized need
is 2 million
51 000 plus sag projects
hundred 3 seven thousand for the fiscal
year 22 amount that you see in the bill
of five million five forty one hundred
eight five million five hundred and
forty eight thousand
nine hundred and thirty five for fiscal
year 2023 the prioritized need is one
million five hundred twenty four
thousand
plus sag projects of five million three
hundred and nine thousand
for the fiscal year 23 amount that you
see in the bill
of six million eight hundred thirty
three thousand
the municipalities on this list have
gone ahead and started these projects
hopeful that funding for the state aid
grant programs
will be appropriated in the fiscal year
22 23 budget
thank you thank you representative
any of the committee members have any
questions
seeing none i will say that i have
gotten letters
and probably all of you have both from
new hampshire river management's
advisory committee
weiler you're you're muted you need to
sorry when i looked up i wasn't muted
all right so there you are
thank you so i
i think that all of us have gotten
letters
in support of this uh one is from new
hampshire water works association
uh from boyd smith executive director
from the municipal association
uh becky benvenuti
from the new hampshire river management
advisory committee
before mentioned becky benvenuti
uh not wishing to testify is in favor
and supports the bill
william hounsell granite street rural
water association north country water
precinct
lower bartlett water precinct is in
support
christina fargo is in support
representing herself
chair trembley from the river management
advisory committee i think i
mentioned a letter from him also uh
packard from the
lakes management advisory committee
connie lane
donna ellis representative self supports
diane schuett merrimack county district
in support uh laura aronson
representing herself in support lucius
partial representing himself in support
uh cecilia rich representing herself in
support
eric rathbun representing himself in
lisa drabik town of londonderry in
support
kate murray is that the same kate murray
we're looking at
but there's a kate murray in support it
is the same i think it's the same
okay so you're actually representing
your district
um herself here yeah okay okay what
whatever
um linda uh harriet linda harriet
gathright representing constituents
in support lisa bunker
myself in the town of exeter she's a
state rep in support
richard demark representing himself
in support jim schmidt
representing himself in support tony
kaplan
representing himself in support and
sherry
gutsy in support these are a lot easier
to read than the pink sheets
representative representative weiler you
you mentioned um
becky benvenuti who has signed up to
testify
oh okay and and also um mr hounzell
i'm not sure if he's uh in our list of
attendees yet
but the they were those were the only
two speakers or the only two
folks who signed up asking to testify
good i guess when they first signed up
they did not mention they wanted to
testify
so is is uh
has been ben venuti available now yes i
can promote her
to panelists all right no no no
uh okay benvenuti from the new hampshire
municipal association
to testify on house bill uh 398
can you hear me now yes go ahead
thank you very much mr chairman and good
morning members of the committee
for the record my name is becky
benvenuti and i am the government
finance advisor
for the new hampshire municipal
association and i'm here today to speak
in support of hb
398. um as senator representative bucco
sorry representative bucco stated this
bill would appropriate
5.7 million for fiscal year 2022 and
6.9 million for fiscal year 2023
to provide initial grant funding for 11
wastewater treatment projects that were
originally slated to receive
state aid grant funding in the current
biennium but due to the pandemics
financial impact
those projects have been placed on hold
plus 110
new hopeful projects which have been
identified by the department of
environmental
services under rsa 486 colon 1
municipalities utilizing that statute
which states that the state of new
hampshire
shall pay annually 20 of the annual
amortization
charges they do finance the full cost of
wastewater projects up front
they complete construction and then um
must be
and then and and only then can they
apply for payment of the state share
which is 20 to 30 percent of the
eligible project costs
usually paid over the amortization
period of the municipal finding which
would be
municipal financing which would be
bonding or
borrowing from the state revolving loan
fund
in the most recent biennium budget
funding
was appropriated for a backlog of 70
projects
which had been subject to a moratorium
since the
period of the great recession all those
projects
were substantially complete by december
and they were funded except for those 11
projects which i
in 1959 when the legislature enacted
the predecessor statute rsa 149a
they recognized that state and federal
government have required
towns and cities to construct wastewater
control systems
to control pollution of surface water
and implode and improve the quality of
water
in for health recreation and industry
purposes
in recognition that these municipalities
have in the past and that others in the
future
will continue to expend significant
taxpayer monies to pay for these systems
in accordance with federal and state
regulations that continue to evolve and
um become more stringent local
municipalities
have moved forward with with these
projects and this
statute is a recognition that the state
should assume its proportionate share of
finite
of financing the obligations resulting
from the installation of these systems
which act not only in the best interests
of
the residents in individual
municipalities but they
they impact the general public health
and welfare
of all citizens in our state these same
principles that were
enacted all those years ago still apply
today
and this funding of this very important
state and local partnership will
continue to apply well into
the future hb 398 is a
as a step forward a step toward
continuing and ensuring that this
critical public health measure that
impacts all residents of the state
can be financially supported and just to
provide you
a little more background of the history
and trends of this funding
over the past years particularly since
the great recession
attached to my testimony is a graft
showing you um the 21-year history of
funding for this projects
and for all these reasons and i'd be
happy to answer any questions we
strongly urge you to support hb 398.
thank you for your time well thank you
miss benvenuti
uh if you have any questions from the
committee please
use the device to raise your hand will
be recognized in order
thank you i do not see any
questions thank you very much for your
testimony
next we have um
william hounsel representing several
uh rural water association and
other organizations i don't see uh mr
hounsell in the list of attendees
representative wyler mr hansel are you
on a phone or
um no i do not see him
in the list online we may come up again
on 4
12. we have a lot of people that wanted
to testify on both
bills or sent us letters concerning both
um let's see if he's down here yes he's
down here also
for the next bill next bill
412 this one is on drinking water the
next one is on waste water
so a lot of these kind of go together
and
trying to keep everything healthy
so going over the list again
and i read it wrong i apologize it did
show that there were a total to testify
of three
that there was support 21 in support and
zero opposed on
house bill excuse me 398.
so that will be looked at in the budget
i think that the reason the money got
left out last time was something that
happened in the senate i'm pretty sure
that we had
put money in those rotating uh
revolving funds when it left the house
but they obviously didn't get put in
so we've got a few more minutes to uh
before we have the 10 o'clock
i'm asking you all uh
we will probably exact these bills
next tuesday uh 10 o'clock look okay for
everybody to do another one of these
zoom meetings i can't see driving up
there for a
short meeting but if we can all
be together again at 10 o'clock next
tuesday
we'll be able to execute these bills
what we've done in the past on the
finance committee
we'll have a bunch of bills that come to
us before we finish the budget
if they're supported by the committee
we'll try to work them into the budget
and obviously these
drinking water and wastewater bills have
been supported in the past and i expect
they will be again
be a matter where we fit them in the
budget and
the frm we previous budget we put that
in as well
and subsequently it was removed by
others but
we'll see what happens that's uh that's
the way we do it with
with bills that come before us before we
finally get to the budget
and
that is the likely outcome but if we're
going to do that we have to have a
meeting we have to exact we have to
uh mark these bills as retained
then if we get them in the budget all
retained bills come up later after our
session
and then the retained bills if they've
been
incorporated in the budget the
original bill becomes mutant we just in
expedient
the bill after we've taken care of that
i see a hand up from
representative hatch representative
hatch you're recognized
go ahead non-mute yourself i i'm sorry
mr chair i
i didn't mean to do that oh
no problem we still got a few minutes to
uh
to talk about things if uh there's
anybody has anything that
i'm looking to see if jess edwards is
still in
the big room yes there he is hello hello
representative edwards
what are you viewing from your position
there
um i i see
long tables all the way down on both
sides this could easily sit
13 people with social distancing there's
at least
three of these um they're not hvac
literally but they're the air
handling systems to handle uh a
decon of the air um
it's uh it's a beautiful day with the
sun streaming through the big windows
and uh i wish there were people here to
to visit with
but uh it's it's i think it's a nice
setup
for a division meeting certainly it
would be easy to get seven people in
here
where everyone could be comfortable do
you see anything on screens
yeah no the screen is approximately uh
20 feet away from me they have some
physical uh
cabling issues that keep it from being
brought
forward more but it's it's about 20
feet from me i see the same zoom
stuff that you see on your home monitor
the
uh i don't have a keyboard with me to to
do the mute and unmute
and the mute and unmute are controlled
from uh the microphone which
uh it's just not intuitive you have to
press red
to talk usually red means don't but
so um so with a little bit of training i
think it's easy to use the microphone
too
well we look forward at some point to uh
either being in that room for
divisions or i guess they're working out
some kinks over in rep's hall that for
the full committee to meet there there's
enough separation
i noticed they have some desks involved
with mics by each desk
that they when they had the senate there
so
reps hall is a possibility for us to
meet
i'm still hearing there's problems
working out with the
sound system so there are many
committees that will probably meet there
and we'll find out how they
they work that out and i'm sitting in
your chair it's very comfortable
i won't get used to it though
all right very good um so
at some point we'll be uh meeting in
that room for divisions
and later on we'll be in the reps hall
for the full committee i hope we all can
make it and
if we have enough bills and obviously
we'll probably be
there for the uh for the some of the
budget hearings
we hear from everybody but most of that
work will be done in divisions
so we've only got a couple of minutes to
go
and does anybody else have anything to
add as far as these sessions or
the bills we have before us we're going
to have 412 next
and we could be getting in position for
that and again that's uh representative
bucco will be presenting that as the
prime sponsor
and a lot of the same people we may see
mr hansel on this one
and i guess we have uh let's see
four people to testify
and we'll hope that we see them all some
uh
becky benvenuto will see it benvenuti
and perhaps we'll see a bill hansel this
time
so another minute we'll get started on
representative this is mike kane uh from
the lba i'll just take 20 seconds
uh so you see an example of rep edwards
in division three
so for division start yes so for
division one and two they'll be using uh
lob202 and llb 207 uh similar setup and
i just wanted to share that with you
when the chair is ready to have hybrid
meetings we will help you out
thank you very much mike you've done a
great job and we're
happy that this has all worked out and
those keys seem to work well
now that you've had it all explained to
me
that control key is magic to get it to
get it up
thank you it being 10 o'clock
i will now call the meeting to order for
house bill
412 and i will recognize the prime
sponsor to introduce house bill 412
for the record my name is tom bucco and
i am a representative from carroll
i appear today to introduce house bill
and to request that the finance
committee recommend this bill ought to
pass
house bill 412 makes appropriations to
des
for funding public water system projects
the funding in this bill is to start up
the state aid program
which has been effectively shut down
since 2008.
the grant funding is an incentive for
municipalities to upgrade
aging water systems and can leverage
additional funding
by complementing the state groundwater
trust fund
and by providing matching funds to
leverage usda rural development grant
and loan programs
please recommend ought to pass on this
bill thank you
thank you representative any committee
members have any questions
please raise your hand if you do
all right i do not see any hands raised
um we next expect to hear from
boyd smith from the uh
public water association
let's see if i got that right yes the
official water works association
smith is he available uh yes chairman uh
weiler this is smith on the line can you
hear me
yes i hear you fine you welcome to the
finance committee
thank you very much um yeah this is
remarkable this
zoom world how we've all adapted to this
and uh
it's not as good as in person but it's a
pretty it's pretty good second i'm glad
we can we can do that
uh good morning everybody i appreciate
your time and i
particularly want to thank
representative bucco for sponsoring this
legislation
my name is boyd smith i'm the executive
director
of the new hampshire water works
association we're an association that
represents
public drinking water entities primarily
across the state and those uh
utilities serve roughly a little over
half a million of our residents
with clean and safe drinking water uh as
as the chair mentioned earlier during
we are in support of both of those bills
um
in large part because many of our
members uh also treat
uh the waste water i say they've got
both ends of the pipe the clean water
and
the wastewater end um i do believe you
have or
have access to a very uh hopefully short
concise
uh letter of testimony that we submitted
late yesterday
what i wanted to do is take a couple
minutes just briefly to maybe put this
concept into perspectives that we can
understand you know this concept of
funding
our drinking water funding our waste
water
by the way you've heard from becky
you'll hear from her again and if you
hear from bill
you'll get more details and expertise
than i can bring to the table but this
is what i wanted to share with you
um water of course is essential
i think anybody that's lost power or
been without water for more than a day
or so
realizes that um
however because we have such a
dependable
public drinking water system and such
amazing people
that operate these systems we we take
water for granted
um to one degree or another but most of
us just turn on the tap and it's there
and it's always there
um again that's because we have
remarkable people
uh teams of professionals treating and
distributing
our drinking water the costs
for this clean water for the service
that we take for granted
really are not well understood
i live in concord uh my combined water
sewer bill
is 25 bucks a month that includes
administrative costs i think five bucks
for water 10 bucks for sewer
i would bet most of us spend more than
that on coffee or a cocktail
but what goes into delivering that clean
water
are large multi-million dollar projects
of
treatment plants water supply protection
miles of pipe to distribute it
hundreds of tests a year to make sure
it's safe
ongoing training to make sure that as
these new standards like pfas or
manganese or arsenic
now lead copper is coming up all these
standards that evolve
we treat our water again so people take
water for granted it's delivered
pretty much flawlessly but most of us
don't understand where it comes from or
what it costs
they're hidden systems uh the state aid
grant which is
what this legislation supports refunding
uh you know re uh re-uh
don't mean refund you know what i mean
allocating funds
to uh truly does leverage on other
funding
my understanding is that this primary
primarily helps
with debt service which is a huge part
of a multi-million dollar multi-year
project
being able to count on it and i just
heard this from
a colleague that runs the water system
in concord
my city put in a multi-million dollar
project
expecting support from the state a grant
12 years ago and as i believe hasn't
received anything yet
so the point that this is statutorily
called for
and pledged and yet the fact it has not
been
uh funded to me is
is an issue that this this group can
address and this legislation can address
um so to sort of sum things up
i think again we know this but i want to
remind us that this is what
we're working on is clean water
and properly treated waste water are all
about
human health as one of our guys once
said uh in the industry
um our product goes in people's mouths
it's
it's very much health related it's very
much economic
uh a driver and it's a priority to
invest
invest not hand out but invest wisely
for effective resilient and sustainable
drinking water
and wastewater infrastructure so
our bottom line is we fully support
governmental
at the state national level investment
in critical infrastructure and drinking
water and wastewater
are all of that we urge you to support
this bill
and our association and our many members
uh stand ready to work with this
committee
i'm going to go in front of the senate
on the omnibus bill this afternoon
this matters to everybody in the state
of new hampshire so we'll do everything
that we can
to provide uh clear communication
sound science uh so we can
have public and private partnerships to
deliver safe drinking water
and clean wastewater uh thank you again
very much for your time
and uh i appreciate it um i'll answer
any questions that i can either now
or later if i have to research them and
i look forward to working
with the committee to move this
legislation forward
thanks again thank you mr smith any
questions from the committee
representative edwards has a question
sir representative edwards
uh thank you thank you mr chair and um i
have
historically lived where there's been
public uh
water supplies and it it's only been
since moving to new hampshire it's made
me want to ask someone the question
of if there's a community that is really
living off of its wells and all three of
my towns do auburn chester and sandown
no public water there what
is the rationale for the citizens of
auburn chester and sandown
to contributing to public water
uh projects that they get no benefit
from and
and and plus they're getting double
dipped because they have to pay for
their own wells
too so i i i don't have an
uh a predisposed answer i'm looking for
i'm just
it's just been a question i've had
kicking around in my head is
you know how does how should the donor
system work
is that i'm sorry sir is that a question
to me or
uh i hope so he's looking for
justification
why public funds should go to uh
to help support water systems that
perhaps
the majority of people in new hampshire
do not get to utilize and i thank you
representative edwards for for the
question and i'll uh
i will give you i think it's a more as
much a philosophical answer
as an economic answer um
and roughly half of our population is
served by
wells private wells and half by public
water
um i think of the benefit of public
uh goes beyond the same myself
at the tab uh say in the city of concord
where we have public water
it supports businesses that uh
you know state of course is a big one
the hospital uh
the schools in the area and my
understanding is roughly
40 000 people almost the population of
concord
migrates in to work in the city
so there's a broad economic benefit that
comes from public water
um i think of the resort communities
uh i know north conway is an example
that
you may have seen testimony from
i don't know how many hundreds of
thousands of people go up to north
conway that
you don't even live in the state but
they spend
millions of dollars uh in the state that
then spreads out to
a lot of people i'm surely including
folks that aren't on the public water
system
and if there wasn't public water up
there you couldn't do it
um the other corollary i think of is
generally and maybe this is
is this question of of public and
government
service um you know my kids
are out of public school uh they have
been for a while
and yet uh we still pay taxes for public
school
um there's roads in the state i'll never
drive on
but uh my taxes or you know your taxes
help support that uh there's things like
medicare there's there's
there's military there's you know
government services of all the
departments
and i may not be using that
myself but the fact that my neighbor can
or a visitor can
often has value so that's
the best i can do with that one sir but
i certainly appreciate your perspective
on that
thank you that answer your question
represent edwards
uh it it does i don't think it's a
question
that has a clear answer i i mean as as i
was listening sir i was
i was thinking about snow plows
uh every town pays for their own snow
plowing because
they need their roads clear and it
benefits them but benefits everyone but
auburn isn't paying for concord's
snow plowing so so i i don't know that
there's an answer to this just a
discussion
thank you representative amberger is
uh sorry ken this is not really a
question but
uh bill hounsell was not able to
initially get on to zoom for the
um the last bill
and i called him on the phone he is now
on zoom and so um
he will be testifying on 4 12.
so i'm i sorry to interrupt but
i wanted to let you know that thank you
representative umberger i had next on my
list was again
becky benvenuti from the new hampshire
can we bring her up mike or nixie
she is joining right now sir there she
is thank you
welcome good morning again thank you
good morning again
committee um again for the record becky
benvenuti government finance advisor for
the nhma
and of course i am here today to speak
in strong support of hb 412.
the bill which provides 500 000
in both fiscal year 2022 and 2023 for
public water supply projects
is extremely important bill and as
the department of environmental services
noted in their fiscal note
using these monies to pay back the 20 to
25 percent of the
annual loan amortization amounts set
forth in rsa 48
486 a could generate a very positive
environmental impact
from a significant number of water
system improvement projects
and what that statute does it provides
an incentive
and it creates affordability for
municipal and community water
systems including the planning and
construction of systems and
partnering with other water systems
interconnection
to increase capacity mitigate water
supply emergencies
and provide high quality clean water for
their residents
while the again it's consolidating and
connecting water systems
is something that's strongly advised and
encouraged by state and federal agencies
the difficulty is that forging these
types of quality partnerships
can be extremely difficult at the local
level without the direct assistance from
either the state or the local government
um i i won't go into you know
specifically what rsa 486a
states but i just think it's important
to you know reiterate recognize that it
does state that
it shall pay shall be eligible um for
these
for these um state aid grants but
there's been a moratorium
on new public water systems state aid
grants since 2008.
in 2013 the program did receive some
funding and governor and executive
council approved drinking water projects
that were retroactive back until
2007 but since that time the program has
remained
unfunded while more than 15 currently
eligible drinking water interconnection
projects await grant approval
and to speak to the earlier question
as the state strives for clean drinking
water consolidation
some of the benefits that do reach all
of new hampshire residents whether i'm
on a private well as well but whether
we're on a private well or public water
system
is it addresses source water
contamination issues it addresses fire
suppression
uh redundant source distribution to many
public water systems
and it achieves a lower health risk and
cost to the general population
from drinking this water the the annual
principal and interest payments
by the state to help construct these
projects
is less than the amount of money that
will come back into the state general
fund which again benefits all of us from
the enhancement of economic development
yesterday there was a large meals and
rooms tax bill and i think that's a
great example that
that boyd gave speaking about north
conway
and the vibrant um
the the vibrant tourist industry that's
up there the meals and rooms taxes
generated
from those entities would not be
possible without
the expansion of these
quality and quantity of the water
interconnection projects
so the funding for this state aid grant
program
would allow municipalities to construct
now while the interest rates are low
and before the costs increase more but
it it does help meet both
local and state goals and we ask you to
please vote to pass
hb 412. thank you
are there any questions from the
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you for your time
let's see if we have bill housel
ready yet i see karen probably
in consultation with him do you know if
he's available
i have promoted him to panelists very
good
all right welcome bill hansel
you had you had him on your on your list
did didn't you
nancy yes um he i'm asking him there he
can you turn on your microphone see you
mr hansel if you if you hear us give me
maybe his uh make sure you've got your
speakers on or
karen try him on the phone again and
tell him
we're not hearing him and i don't think
he's hearing us
thanks karen yeah um
he's going to call in okay
okay and he said he was doing that right
now
so hopefully it will
i don't know what i don't know what the
problem is i just know that
he wants to testify so
well and i think
nancy there is a way he can he can go
and join us on the phone right
yes but i believe he just comes in here
as a phone number which i don't yet
see
audio i need to update my computer
all right we're hearing you
okay i apologize for the delay
if i could speak uh to uh hp 398 i would
like to
so that i congratulate the committee on
what they did last session to
to bring us up to current on the
projects that would do and deserving of
principal interest payments
it is now in position to
keep us current and the list of projects
on the 2022 list are projects that
are making payments now and so this is
an important
thing to recognize as we look at this
budget and send it to division one
for review and and always say that the
same bill is being heard on the senate
finance side at the same time so
the way we did it last time seemed to
work pretty well and i'm hoping that
this this bill will uh at least tom
bucco and karen's bill will
will raise this issue to the level of
priority to give it the credence it's
deserving of
these these federal regulatory drivers
that force the
in the state new hampshire department of
environmental services
of course are the ones that oversee the
enforcement of the
federal clean water act
are the are driving the communities to
do what needs to be done to keep our
waterways clean and also
to treat the the water the drinking
water
that it comes back out in order to
protect our aquifers and source of
drinking water
there's no more project no more
partnership and funding is
that it's as vital as this state aid
grant program
it was this particular bill was put in
place in 1993
to address the surface water treatment
rule
and it also uh was in
combination with with the need of
wastewater to clean up
the drinking water so before we had
cultures of two different
different breeds if you will drinking
water was one culture wastewater was
another
in recent years we've come to understand
that they're one they're one in the same
we in order to protect the source of our
drinking water we have to build these
plants to treat our water as we put it
back
into the ground so so
as we talk about the wastewater aspect
it also links in with 412 which is the
drinking water aspect
the wastewater aspect really happens
because the communities at the local
level
trust that that partnership is reliable
that the state put this partnership in
place in law
to be to be a funding partner and to pay
annual principal and interest portions
between
20 and 30 percent on projects that are
uh deserving of uh of
the affordability index and that that's
based on rates
uh 20 is for a normal race but stress
rates get 30 percent
and some of the bonds are 20 years long
some are 30 years long so these
projections that you see before you
are based on the department of
environmental service staff
projections which are pretty accurate
i think if we can budget for the total
view that we're looking at instead of
part of the view
we would we would come to a more flat
line and we've talked about this in past
years
a more flatline way of funding these
programs
to give a reassurance and trust and
reliable confidence when they pass the
bonds at the local level
that this partnership is reliable is
dependable and that
our legislators understand it and and
take a position to to support and fight
for that uh
consistent funding program um
i i think that's what i would like to
say about the wastewater
and then i would uh if you if you don't
mind i would shift gears and go into the
the bill that's before you now house
hospital 412 is
is a new new view of what we haven't
been doing
we have been so concentrated on
getting all those projects that were
paying bond debts at the local level on
the wastewater side
that's a moratorium that went on to the
drinking water side
in 2008 kind of laid in limbo without
any
again when i when when that was put in
it was the bill was put in
i wrote the bill in in the early 90s
to address the surface water treatment
rule which was
a federal rule that said that if you had
an open source of water you had to
either
build a filtration plant or cover your
water storage
tanks and it was again that for federal
regulatory drivers was imposing greater
consequences of cost on the
municipalities to comply with the
federal drivers
so that law when we would put it in
place all of a sudden all of the
communities that hadn't been taking
action came forward and started doing
building these
these systems and that partnership made
it affordable so they could see at the
local level
a reason uh to do it and not
they've always wanted to do it at the
local level but
as you well know most bonds will not
be passed unless the people are very
confident when they put their
property up as collateral against those
bonds that they can make those payments
they have that confidence when the state
comes in
with within a partnership in grants that
makes it affordable by the state's
state and federal government's own
formulas of affordability
so it's not a giveaway program it's a
program that that makes things happen
that wouldn't happen
otherwise and i i believe that's where
we are now we've completed the surface
water treatment rule
but in later years we added the
interconnection grant program
the interconnection grant program has
been in limbo since 2008 and that's why
what we're trying to resuscitate this
500 000 would start
uh supporting the 16 million worth of
projects
that are on the list now and i i've
given a list
some of those projects on the written
comments that i gave you
five five five hundred thousand would
support some of the des staff that's
necessary to oversee this but it also
would support the
four hundred and twelve thousand dollar
a year payments on those 16 million
dollars worth of local debt
uh to to do this consolidation
uh here here is a tremendous bang for
your buck
because when you start to interconnect
those systems
you start to pick up a lot of the little
water systems along the way there
that are stressed or drinking naturally
contaminated water a lot of which
the people don't know about i could cite
to you for instance attitude mountain
between
lower bartlett and bartlett village
which has
on their peak many many people coming
down skiing and stopping in a little
restaurant and bar
area and drinking the water that is has
natural contaminants in it
without even knowing it and they don't
know it because
it's a it's it's it's a transient system
that's not regulated by the federal
drivers and
that gives them deficiency reports but
we know it we know it at the local level
and the state's aware of it
and we need to treat those people that
come into our state and drink that water
as if they were our own citizens and a
project like the connection between
lower bartlett and bartlett village
starts to handle those
types of issues as an example it also
would allow for economic growth that
would
occur as a result of the quality and
quantity of water that would be provided
up there
and it gives redundancy for instance the
bartlett village by interconnecting
a lower bartlett village to to water
system to
bartlett village water system we have by
the use of this program
connected conway village fire district
to north conway village prior
to north conway water precinct the use
of these grants we made it affordable
those bonds pass
and that has happened think of the
marvelous accomplishment when you
connect uh a water systems
sub governments they keep their own
autonomy their own entities they control
their own destinies
but they link to each other and
consolidate the sources
if something should happen to one source
a truck skill or a
rollover fuel getting into it or
something along those
the aquifer they can shut down that well
and draw water from other sources
along the with the length of mount
washington valley
that is exactly exactly the kind of
system that supports
the regional opportunities for the kind
of people that
the quantity of people that come into
that valley
i would tell you that north conway
bartlett jackson that whole valley has a
seasonal population of 15
000 but overnight on a friday night of
good skiing and in the summer when the
weather is
beautiful and this hiking is what the
people and being in the river is what
the people desire
they they come in to the quantity of
about 34 000.
that's that's the size of the city of
rochester so
when you look at these small systems and
you look at these little village
districts you've got you have to realize
the tremendous economic value it has to
the state
for uh for the investment that the state
puts into annual principal interest
payments to support this amazing amazing
debt
at the local level 10 million dollars
flat line budget on on these kinds of
programs on on the sag programs
accommodates hundreds of millions of
dollars of local debt
i i i won't go on any anymore because
i i know uh becky's covered marvelously
and
and and as as boyd smith the the other
backgrounds of health and economic
activity and growth and
um and all of the issues that uh they so
are so well verbalized but
i i think it's a key battle it's a
priority battle for the budget
if there's anything that helps help
reduce the cost of health and human
services
it's investment in water infrastructure
every dollar you put into this sag
program will yield much more back into
the general fund
than you invest in it it's really really
a no-brainer to be doing what we're
doing
and i thank you for listening to me
thank you mr householder any of the
all right seeing none
on house bill 412
i have uh four people to testify and
they have
i have 17 in support zero opposed
in essence of time i won't read all the
names again
but most of them when i did uh
398 a lot of the same people so
you've heard uh the talk on both
wastewater and drinking water
and that will be discussed and hopefully
we will be able to fit it into the
budget
it's not a huge amount
there's no questions for any of the
people on that i will close the hearing
on house bill 412
and we will move on to the 10 30
bill which 623
and we'll recognize this is an education
bill will recognize the prime sponsor
hi representative it's mickey i'm here
now mr chair
thank you all right representative leno
welcome to finance committee
thank you very much mr chair so for the
record and i'm just trying to
clear something off here um for the
record my name is dave luno
um representing uh merrimack the people
of merrimack district 10
which are the towns of hopkinton in the
western part of the city of um
of concord and um and my apologies i got
to start with a with a
with sort of a point of personal um uh
privilege
um i'm also in a in an exec session
in uh in a house education zoom right
now so if i'm distracted for a vote
um please uh please bear with me um
but um but a unifying theme throughout
the
school funding commission's work is
based on the data
that we that were reviewed and the
substantial testimony and comment
received
is that education funding policy should
be guided by
the fundamental concept that any
solutions must focus
on all of our students funding policies
must be student-centered
and designed to create equal opportunity
in order to narrow the achievement gaps
associated with poverty and other forms
of social disadvantage
closing those gaps for all students
regardless of their needs or where they
live
became the shared vision among
commission members
with respect to fiscal policy the
commission found that new hampshire's
current system of funding fails to
direct
aid to more needy communities in a
meaningful manner
and inequities manifest themselves in
more needy districts
through lower student outcomes and
higher property tax burdens
i think we're probably all familiar with
that key findings from the school
funding commission
center on student outcomes a combination
of student performance on statewide
assessment tests
graduation rates and attendance rate
overall new hampshire students perform
very well
and in fact rank among the best in the
country but we also found that in
districts with higher incidences
of poverty student outcomes are well
below state average
and these uh school districts spend less
on education
than do districts serving more affluent
communities
the commission looked at 10 years of
data from new hampshire schools
specifically student and community
characteristics student outcomes
and how money is spent and developed a
formula to estimate the cost for every
district
to educate students to a statewide
outcome
and we developed a funding formula using
local taxes
and then the limited state funds that we
have to make sure that every student has
access to the resources they need
it doesn't break the bank and it doesn't
require new taxes
so what what i'd like to do um mr chair
is um is is talk specifically about uh
house bill 623
which is directed to stabilize state
funding
for fiscal years 22 and 23
the the coming biennium and fy 22
is the is the school uh budgets
that school boards and budget committees
around the state are all
uh are all working on right now and will
be a subject of um
uh annual district annual meetings
coming up in the next months
so so the uh the reason to uh to
stabilize
um school fun state funding for these
two years is really
as a result of three things number one
the pandemic
and um and it also um restores
the need-based funding that was um
so important uh in the in the
committee's commission's recommendations
that what was included uh for school
districts in the fy 21 budget
uh uh the need based funding is uh is
certainly
it's a key recommendation from the
commission the um
state grants to schools are calculated
in rsa 198
40 and 41 and the adequacy grant
is calculated based on the prior year
enrollment
so for fy 22 the enrollment or the adma
which is the average daily
daily membership and attendance is based
on students counts reported to the new
hampshire department of education
back on october 1st 2020. so
um so these adma numbers
are um are there
there's quite a quite a huge dramatic
difference from from what we saw
on on october 1st 2020 to what
um what we saw on october 1st on 2019.
so uh 2019 the adma and this is from the
from the department spreadsheets was
about 167
000 well it was exactly 167 298 students
and um and a year later um the the
enrollment that we would be basing
school funding on for the coming year
is uh is is almost is more than seven
thousand less
uh 160 191 um
that um that disparity
is uh is further um uh uh
amplified in the free and reduced price
lunch count um uh uh students and and uh
and
i think we all recognize that uh that
free and reduced
price lunch is a is a key component of
the differentiated aid
calculation that specifically helps
school districts serving um more
more impoverished populations
and that count dropped from five
thousand six hundred eighty six
to thirty four thousand um six hundred
twenty eight
so uh so a huge huge drop there what is
it what does it do as far as
as far as um adequacy fund or or the
state grants to school districts is
concerned well
it um it reduces base adequacy this is
for all districts by more than 12
million dollars
it reduces the free and reduced price
lunch differential aid
by almost 24 how much would i say 12
million dollars in base
the free and reduced price lunch
differentiated aid
by nearly 24 million dollars the um
and then the uh the need-based um grants
for fiscal disparity
which go away in fy 22 amount to another
and a half million dollars and the um
the
need-based grant for free and reduced
price lunch
which also disappears in fy 22 is nearly
uh nearly 50 million dollars actually i
had those two numbers back
the disparity is 50 million and free and
reduced price lunch is another 12
million
um what um what that means for
manchester
is really eye-opening um uh just in the
adequacy
uh component alone um
manchester state adequacy grant would
fall from 14 and a half million dollars
to just under 10 million dollars and the
um the need-based um grants for
for fiscal disparity and free and
reduced price lunch
would fall by over seven million dollars
that's just to manchester
and you know that's the largest school
district in the state
serving nearly thirteen thousand
students and um
uh and and students that that on average
are underperforming state um uh state
outcomes
uh significantly so um statewide
it's a 90 million dollar um uh
loss in funding and uh and i think the
the report that
that uh that the um that the committee
will receive from the lba
uh bears that out on a on a town by town
and district by district
basis um so so that's the
that's the the number one thing that
house bill 623 does the
the second thing is um is is not as
big a dollar amount but it's still an
important factor
and uh and it's actually got to do with
um
with full day kindergarten startup
grants which
which were were certainly uh certainly
an important uh
consideration back when full-day
kindergarten funding was
uh was was was brought on board several
years ago
um and um and uh what we had noticed
last year and i had introduced the bill
house bill 1691
uh that um that apparently when
when changes were made to the full-day
kindergarten program
the startup grant element of it was
inadvertently dropped
and what the startup grant means is that
on the first year
a um a district offers full day
kindergarten that
those full um the st
all the students in that in that class
on october 1st
are counted towards their adequacy grant
and because you know like we were just
talking about
the adequacy grant um trails by one year
so so we didn't want to we didn't want
to penalize uh school districts in the
first year
or disincentivize them from from
implementing full day kindergarten
so um so unfortunately 1691 which
cleared the house education committee
20 to nothing and then went to your
committee
uh back in march ended up dying at the
end of uh
in the session that bill was rolled in
to the education omnibus bill house bill
1558 in section 2
which which adopted the language from um
from from house bill 1691 but
in uh in that flurry of activity at the
end of last session
the effective date was uh was not
amended so
in order to uh to capture school
districts that
that implemented uh full-day
kindergarten
uh during during fy20 you need to have
an effective date that's also in fy 20
and uh and unfortunately the effective
date on that um
missed that by uh by 29 days so house
bill 623
rectifies that effective date problem
and
uh what you can see in the um
in the in the fiscal note for um
for 623 is
um is this on the last page of the
fiscal note
the uh the fiscal year 2020 first year
programs
it affects the districts of chester
salem and windham
it's a total of eight hundred and forty
thousand dollars
that that they all fully expected to
receive
um and uh and didn't receive
due to um due to you know
just due to our own legislative uh
uh uh issues and uh the fiscal mode also
goes on to
show fy 2021 first year programs
but that's already in the law so so
that's nothing
that's nothing new there so with that
i'm happy to
conclude my my introductory remarks
take any questions but but leave it up
to the the very
um you know capable people who are going
to be uh
thank you representative luno any
questions from the committee members
karen representative umberger and then
are you going to provide your uh
test testimony in a written form to
the finance committee
yeah i can i can i can certainly do that
if that's uh helpful
i um it's it's um um just
scratched out long hand right now but
how about if i type it up
and um and and email that to um
to you okay that that would be very
helpful
i have i if i could i have a follow-up
the as i understand it
in 2021 there was
additional money provided to the
school districts for them to
improve some infrastructure work i'm
sorry i don't know what that dollar
value was
but are you excluding that
from the um from the bill
yeah thank you very much thank you very
much for the uh for the question yeah
that's not uh that's not part of this
bill
that's the uh the i think it was called
the capital infrastructure grants
and um uh and they were they were they
were
they were specifically designed to i
think improve safety and security
within uh within public school buildings
and uh i believe that program has uh
has wrapped up now but no that's got
nothing to do with any of the numbers in
this bill
okay but when when i read the bill
it says it won't be less than
what was provided in the past pri
in the prior year it doesn't say that it
excludes
the um infrastructure grants
and so that was a concern that i had
and so what you're telling us is
actually to go back well to look at
2021 excluding
the infrastructure grant is that correct
that's that's
that's correct uh representative
bumberger and um
and you know the the language in the
bill
in in item e it talks about the total
education grant
so so that is that is something that um
and the the
the lba has that uh uh uh
defined very accurately i believe in
their in their fiscal note
to be the the combination of the
adequacy grant the fiscal disparity um
grant the enhanced free and reduced
lunch grant the stabilization grant
and the excess swept grant um and the
and the swept grant
that that is uh that is provide
thank you very much to um through the
state to school districts
thank you representative heath for a
question
thank you mr chair and um thank you
representative luno uh
i think we all realize what our local
school districts are going
through right now it's a tough time
the intent of your bill i believe
and correct me if i'm wrong is to really
make school districts whole at this
point in time
for the losses that they will incur from
extreme drops in enrollment
and also in terms of the free and
reduced
lunch funds that they would have gotten
because of the fact that children are
not attending schools am i correct
no that's that's that's completely
correct um
the the the first part when we talk
about
holding them harmless to the the drop of
enrollment
that's of no fault of school districts i
mean that is completely pandemic related
um uh enrollment um um
decline that is totally uh just
with a disconnect of of from the from
the
sort of annual 1 ish decline that we've
been seeing so
you know this is enormous declines you
know 25
decline in free and reduced price lunch
i think decline in in total enrollment
so so uh so that that's not that's not
out of the
sort of the normal course the other two
are um
are are not pandemic related but but
clearly
our our student equity and taxpayer
equity related
which i think during a pandemic sort of
cert certainly have a
a bearing given the additional cost that
school districts are facing
and the additional stress that um that
that all
students are um are under so um so
i think that's why um that's why this
bill includes
um those two uh grants as well
oh thank you and i would also appreciate
a copy of your testimony thank you oh no
no i'll i'll send it
i'll send it to the committee thank you
thank you
any other questions all right we'll let
representative leno get back to
executing in the education bills
all right thank you very much mr chair
thank you members
take care all right next one to speak is
lindsey picard
do we have her in the waiting room nancy
she's been promoted
and so she should be able to speak very
good
good morning good morning mr card oh
i didn't expect to be first i apologize
bear with me just one quick moment
thank you for your time this morning um
for uh
giving me an opportunity to speak before
the before the committee with regard to
this house bill 623 i am in favor
of this house bill as a
lifelong resident of new hampshire and
currently a school board representative
for my local district
we are on the front lines of watching
our community be pit against each other
as we battle appropriate adequate
education
and the balance of our property taxes
in the last five years that i've sat on
the school board locally
i have seen uh fluctuations in
anticipated revenue from the state
jump and reduce our overall property tax
by several dollars every year
when you say several dollars that
doesn't sound like
a lot of money until you start
multiplying that by
of course uh your your property values
and you realize that your revenues and
what you might be responsible for
offsetting through taxation
can change hundreds of thousands of
dollars
last year what happened in our local
district
with this reduction in overall revenues
anticipated from the state
and having to make that up from our
property taxpayers
was i would say nothing short of a
revolt by multiple
taxpayers and ultimately a reduction of
one point six million dollars
to our budget to be very clear
out of that one point six million that
was reduced
over nine hundred thousand dollars of
our increased budget was
strictly tuition based so
what that means is while our contractual
obligations
to our teachers to the bus company
to um you know the state of new
hampshire retirement for our teachers to
the pension
while all of that remains the same we
are tasked with reducing a significant
input and impacting a significant amount
of money
that meant that we had to take away
busing
to our high schoolers so our parents are
made responsible for transporting their
students
to our into our matriculating district
which is 25 minutes from us
we also reduced staff by 23 staff
members
coming into a pandemic you can imagine
that has placed
a lot of burden in addition to this
pandemic on our parents
on our students concerned about
transportation to high school
and on our local elementary and middle
school as that staff
grapples with trying to provide
excellent remote education and on-site
education
reduced by 23 staff i think it's really
important that the state of new
hampshire
not just continue to put forward a stop
gap
in funding but also develop appropriate
funding for us moving forward but in the
interim
this bill in ensuring that for at least
the immediate future
our residents our students and our staff
have stability in what they can expect
for
funding from the state thank you again
for your time
and i i understand that it's appropriate
to take questions so i suppose if there
is one or several
i am available uh thank you mr
card representative petrie has a
question yes so
who do you represent uh ms picard
um i am yep the winchester
school district we are sau 94.
very good thank you thank you
any further questions representative
umberger
uh thank you mr chairman um miss
miss picard is your school district
currently uh doing face-to-face learning
or is it all remote our school district
is
currently all remote but only due to the
recent
um uptick in covet 19 cases in our
immediate area
our plan is to head back into our hybrid
if i might follow up please follow up
so are you saying that you were doing
face-to-face learning and then
stopped we were doing face-to-face
learning
in a hybrid model with most of our
students on campus two days a week
um and then rotating through two days a
week up until
uh november so yes we had been doing
face to face
and we do continue to even through uh
the pandemic where we've been
shut down to most face to face
we of course continue to offer all of
the students
thank you any further questions from the
committee
seeing none thank you very much mr
picard if
testimony written out it would be
appreciative of it
i don't know sing that in our emails or
the next person up to speak is
jeff mclinch new hampshire school
funding fairness project
is mr lynch available
jeff you should be good to go thank you
thank you very much uh can everyone hear
me all right yes
wonderful well chairman weiler
representative walner members of the
committee
thank you so much for the opportunity to
testify this morning on house bill 623
for the record my name is jeff mcclinch
and i'm the project director of the new
hampshire school funding fairness
project
the aim of house bill 623 is clear
simple
and essential it seeks to put a floor
under the education aid that the state
provides to cities and towns
and ensure that for each of the next two
years every community
receives at least the same amount of
education aid that they receive at
present
given the long-standing problems that
plague new hampshire's school funding
system
as well as the new challenges students
families and schools face
i cannot urge the committee strongly
enough to recommend house bill 623 as
ought to pass
moreover as communities across new
hampshire are already weighing difficult
budgetary decisions for the coming year
i would similarly urge the committee to
act on 623 as quickly as possible
and i just want to underscore a couple
of points that are made to date
uh in setting uh education aid at for 22
and 23
um at no less than what it receives in
the current year the bill would achieve
two important ends
first it would preserve the progress
that the legislature made under the
current budget
in bolstering state education aid and
targeting it to those cities and towns
most in need
as representative luna explained um the
budget agreement added two elements to
the funding formula for fiscal 21
additional aid which is intended to
assist cities and towns
with higher concentrations of low-income
students and fiscal capacity disparity
aid which is designed to help you miss
municipalities with comparatively low
property values
as these two forms of aid begin to take
steps toward addressing two of the flaws
inherent in new hampshire's current
approach
to funding in schools they should be
extended and maintained until more
comprehensive reforms are adopted
second the bill would help to protect
against the pandemic's possible
impact on school finances and uh
representative luna detailed these to
some degree
um as it stands right now i believe the
data from the department of education uh
indicate
a roughly four percent decline in adm
overall and a nearly 25 decline in free
and reduced price lunch
adm um you know and the vast majority of
school districts have seen these numbers
decline in one form or to one degree or
another
now both sets of numbers almost surely
rebound as the pandemic wayne's
and his school resume in person classes
full time
during the 21 22 academic year but again
because of the time lag
that's baked into the formula those
temporary lower numbers will be used to
decide the amount of eight districts
receive
uh in the coming academic year even as
attendance
slowly climbs back toward normal levels
the bill recognizes that the student
counts we're seeing now that those
estimates we're seeing now
are not likely to reflect the situation
schools will face this fall
and thus sets fiscal 21 funding amounts
as a reasonable floor
without action along the lines of house
bill 623
state education age is expected to fall
by some 90 million dollars between the
current year and next
such a drop would force many cities and
towns to turn to significant property
tax increases
or severe spending cuts as they set
their school budgets for the next year
the scale of such property tax increases
could drive the bills homeowners face up
by hundreds of dollars for instance if
property tax rates um
were the mechanisms cities and towns
were to use to address those gaps
more than 20 of them would have to
resort to rate increases in excess of
two dollars per thousand of assessed
value
just to give another example in an area
like farmington for instance
a family with a home worth two hundred
thousand dollars could see their
property tax bill go up by more than
four hundred dollars
to close that gap if the town were to
turn solely to property tax increases
to conclude i once again urge the
committee to recommend house bill 623 is
out to pass
and to do so as expeditiously as
possible
i and the organization new hampshire
school funding fairness project
look forward to working with the members
of the committee to try to address these
issues
and i'd be happy to answer any questions
you may have this morning
thank you mr mcclinch any questions from
representative heath has a question
thank you mr chair
and thank you mr mc lynch for your
testimony
um i just want to go back to your um
request that we fast track this bill
um and the need to do that could you
just reiterate again
um the um essential uh need to
um move this bill along please
yes um as uh the sponsor of the bill
alluded cities and towns are already in
the process of setting their budgets for
the coming year
so um waiting until uh the state budget
as a whole is passed
would not be as effective if it were to
be acted upon quickly
it would help help shape the decisions
they're making now
and i know because of the pandemic
there's some fluidity this year
to to that budget setting process um
there may be
uh towns are are going to approve their
budgets more quickly but there are
others that may be waiting until may or
so
to do so so acting now would be in
everyone's best interest
thank you representative
thank you uh representative weiler
um mr mclynch can you expand
a little bit on the um issue around the
free and reduced
did i thought i understood
that there was uh federal regulations
that had been um actually
loosened up during the pandemic around
the applications and so that's part of
why we're having the free and reduced
issue
that's correct there is a federal
initiative again due to the pandemic
to try to uh ease the process of
providing food assistance to families
that does not require them to complete
the paperwork that they would normally
use
and that paperwork in turn is normally
used to provide accounts of free and
reduced price large students for schools
so even though um you know hunger issues
may be every bit
as biting or even worse in the pandemic
right now
the number of free reduced price alleged
students has declined precipitously
not because they're better off because
they're no longer hungry but because the
federal government is using a different
approach
to providing that assistance that
assistance i believe has been extended
through the end of the school year
i don't know that it's going to continue
um beyond
the current school year so that come
this fall you could see that rebound
in uh free reduced price lunch
enrollments
just as the lower aid is beginning to
take hold
if we don't do something
thank you any follow-up
[Music]
all right any further questions from the
committee
i'm saying none thank you sir
thank you all right next on the list
is carl ladd from the new hampshire
school administrators association
good morning mr chairman thank you very
much for taking my testimony for the
record my name is carl latt i'm the
executive director of the new hampshire
school administrators association
uh i'm not going to take up a lot of
your time this morning you heard
mr mc lynch's testimony and we would
echo
the sentiments raised by mr mc lynch
we do know that school districts are
faced with
a significant fiscal impact
in both in the next fiscal year as well
as the one following
and we know that a lot of this had
nothing to do with
school districts providing a high
quality education to their children
it is all coveted related and while the
enrollments may be going down right now
and we know that there has been a
traditional
unless we hold districts harmless for
the next year
or two years uh it's going to be
difficult to determine whether that
enrollment
uh is merely uh that enrollment
uh drop is merely a blip or whether it
is going to
continue districts need to be able to
make plans
and be able to budget appropriately and
school districts and taxpayers need to
have the understanding of what their tax
bills
are going to look like moving forward
i did just want to mention very briefly
the free and reduced
lunch that representative heath brought
up and mr mcclinch
answered it was definitely a um
a gift from the usda um
when the pandemic first began that
a lot of the requirements for free lunch
were eliminated and essentially all
students
uh qualified for free and reduced lunch
the problem with that now is that we
have a number of
families who have not submitted free and
reduced
applications and trying to get those uh
at this point is
uh incredibly difficult so it was a
double-edged sword
uh very helpful especially during the
beginning stages of the pandemic
but less so now that we're trying to
deal with funding
so i would just request
that that the committee consider
moving this bill very very quickly we
have deliberative sessions
on annual meetings that are already
gearing up and getting ready
deliberative sessions have already
occurred where districts have put
forward significant budget cuts
to deal with the expected decrease
in finance for the upcoming fiscal year
and we would strongly urge you to
vote this bill through and i'll be glad
to answer any questions
at this time thank you mr chairman thank
you mr ladd any questions from the
committee
i don't see any hands up so appreciate
barrett christina from the new hampshire
thank you chairman weiler thank you
members of the committee for the record
of barrett christina executive director
of the new hampshire school boards
association
uh just as the preceding speakers have
said were in
full support of this bill most of the
points that nhsba was going to make
relative to house bill 623 have already
been made by the
by the previous speakers but if i could
just reiterate again that
um passing this bill is going to be a
significant relief to local property
taxpayers
we know that our enrollment numbers are
very skewed this year
due to the pandemic i'm sure as
everybody on the committee knows
that school funding in new hampshire is
based
um primarily on on our enrollment
numbers there's a lag
in getting those for for obvious
budgetary reasons
um you know we're educating kids this
year perhaps with fewer kids in the
building or fewer kids enrolled
within our school districts based on
last year's uh
enrollment numbers and we certainly know
that when enrollment numbers are
submitted by local school districts to
the department of education
um in the fall of 2021 they're going to
be artificially lower
um so then funding in subsequent years
through state funding in subsequent
years is going to
um reflect those artificial numbers i
would like to make one other aspect
relative to the
the free and reduced uh free and reduced
uh lunch numbers
um representative heath you certainly
know this and representative petry you
certainly know this um
with um you know your background in in
working for school districts and mr
petrie your work on the
the farmington school board for a number
of years our free and reduced lunch
numbers are
lower than what they actually are in
normal circumstances
many parents don't want to fill out that
paperwork either
because of the stigma or because of uh
they're proud they're too
too too proudful to want to accept that
help
so our free and reduced lumber numbers
that we report to the state are actually
lower than the numbers that were act of
of the food that were actually
and the kids that were actually serving
um so because of the the waivers um
with the the usda and and relaxation of
some of the regulations of the um
from the federal government while it's
helpful because it's still putting food
in kids mobs it's
it's not helpful from a state funding um
perspective relative to the system that
we have in new hampshire
um you know under the the differentiated
aid for the number of kids on free and
reduced lunch
so um i don't have anything new to add
other than i certainly want to thank ms
picard from the winchester
school board for highlighting the
challenges that are going to be going on
i'm in winchester with their current
budget crisis but um more than anything
nhsb again would just like to reiterate
that this is going to be a very very
helpful bill for local property
taxpayers
especially school districts are moving
through their budget season right now
um as it's been previously mentioned uh
nothing else to add with that i'm happy
to take any questions from the committee
thank you mr christina any questions
from the committee
seeing none thank you sir thank you
mr chair all right
the next speaker i have on the list is
uh mayor donchius from nashua is he
available
he is here now and is available to speak
or able to speak
thank you mick please bring him up
um is am i up mr chair i lost connection
for a minute jim doncic
we can hear you mayor okay thank you i
did i lost the connection um
the um thank you mr chair for uh
entertaining me um i'm going to
reinforce what some of the other
speakers have said i of course the mayor
of nashua and i
i'm speaking on behalf of our school
district which has 11 000 students
i can focus on our numbers not because
they're different or more important than
someone else's but just because i can
give you because i know them but we we
would suffer a multi-million dollar loss
in school aid
causing either a cut in educational
services
or you know teachers probably or
a major increase in property taxes in
our case the
increase is approaches five million
dollars
and the such a cut comes right at the
long time
we are remote right now but we are we
are
there the school district is scheduled
to go back to
um reinstituting hybrid learning
starting
next week and comes at the wrong time
because we know
across the state we're suffering serious
learning loss among kids who've been
trying to learn remotely
and maybe haven't been successful in
doing that
or who are not even able to connect
remotely
that's true in some cases and we
we need to help these help these kids
and get them back to their grade levels
if at all possible
but the reductions in school aid as
you've already heard are caused
principally by the lower
population numbers the lower census
numbers and the lower free and reduced
lunch
numbers these are artificially low right
now
with respect to free and reduced lunch
usda the federal government basically
made lunches free for anybody any kid
which is good great i mean now
maybe kids who are on the margins or
need
need help otherwise maybe don't qualify
get get the free meals but
the incentive for free and reduced lunch
qualifying families uh there's no
incentive anymore to fill out the
paperwork because they can get
free and reduced lunch without doing
that and
in our case the school district has got
maybe two-thirds of the kids to sign up
or families to sign up but uh not
all of them and so the very precipitous
decline is not based on less kids but
based upon
this uh inability to get paperwork done
we may have more free and reduced kids
than we had before because
some of the service lower income workers
have been
laid off as part of the pandemic number
two
uh mr chair the are the
there's the reduction in census total
census
now in our case the school district
reports that
the vast majority of the loss and census
is among the kindergarten and
pre-kindergarten
groups of parents and they believe
that those kids are going to come back
as soon as school is open but for a
kindergartner
you know to try to learn remotely
just or pre-kindergarten is you know
just not
going to work so a lot of or not work
very well
so a lot of parents just haven't signed
up so
in the end the vast majority of the kids
in our case the loss is about 200
excuse me about 800 would will come back
to the school district
so for all those reasons i hope mr chair
that the committee will consider
recommending the bill for to pass
because school districts across the
state are facing the same
problem you've heard about it from small
towns now from a larger city
we're all facing the same problem and we
want to maintain educational quality
coming out of the pandemic
thank you mayor any questions from the
seeing none i appreciate you coming and
and giving us some numbers
specific to nashville all right thank
you very much
all right any any more from the
committee
nancy or mick anybody else waiting to
testify
i see no hands raised among the
attendees
oh hold on we do have one now one just
went up i have a
michael bessette available okay
hello can you hear me yes thank you for
letting me have the opportunity to spend
a little time with you today
um my name is michael bisset and for the
record i'm the assistant superintendent
of the kearsarge regional school
district and i will not repeat
all the the wonderful testimony that has
been shared already
i too am in support of this bill
but i wanted to give you a little bit of
perspective from kearsarge's point of
view
if i could hirsarge is a is a school
district that's made up of seven towns
we have an enrollment of about eighteen
hundred and sixty students
who are in our school district and i
just wanted to let you know that um
just some some information about how our
year is played out
um for us someone uh i believe it was
representative
umberger had asked the question had we
been in school or school has your school
been
in session throughout the year in person
and the answer for us has been yes
we've maintained a schedule since the
the start of the school year in which
we've created
um basically a synchronized learning
model in which we have three one-hour
blocks of instruction
that are offered to our parents
throughout the day
for them to have remote at home learning
and that is synchronized with our
in-person learning services and so
we we knew from the get-go in august
that we were going to have some families
that were going to take us up on that
that offer um to give you some
understanding of how our enrollment
shifted a little bit
in october of 2019 we had 126
home-schooled students
at october of 2020 that number
shifted and was up to an additional 90
students who had enrolled in home school
based on their inability for the most
part to
work within the unpredictability
of potentially having to shut down the
school district for periods of up to 14
days to deal with
quarantining needs in their classrooms
we've been very fortunate
that the whole district has only shut
down twice i do believe for extended
periods around vacation schedules
for up to 14 days but we have had a
number of parents impacted by the fact
that
we've had to quarantine classrooms and
that's with six foot distancing
teachers wearing the best ppe that we
could afford to purchase can 95 masks
religiously
we've done our jobs we have had zero
transmission of student to staff in
relative to covent but all of those
impacts aside
we've watched those homeschooling
numbers shift in october from 90
up to 106 homeschooling students because
of the unpredictability
of the situation that they're having to
contend with they opted for
um knowing exactly what things would be
over
over the conditions that we were trying
to provide
that said when we talked to all of those
homeschooling students we know that
by far the 106 additional homeschoolers
that we see now
and compared to the 90 that we had in
october
we know that in talking with them
they're going to return back to our
school full they've told us flat out
it's a question that we ask them when
they inform us they are telling us that
they want to come back but they want the
security of covid and the vaccinations
to be in play before they do so
we're one to take a look at the impact
of those financials
just on that pool alone as we start to
look at adequacy aid
alone all things being equal moving into
next year
we're looking at about a three hundred
thousand dollar impact on that
population of students
alone on the adequacy monies that are
assigned to them so
i just wanted you to have that number
and had three hundred thousand dollars
based on that shift of 106 students to
homeschooling
alone if you compound that a little bit
you realize that about five out of our
seven
towns that make up our school district
receive those adequacy funds in order to
offset the property taxes and such so
i think there's a substantial community
impact that's related to that
that represents by the way about nine
percent of our
overall 2.9 million dollars
that's assigned to adequacy funds to
impact our student learning
i think the only thing i would also add
to this is that sometimes we look at
these things in isolation but
i would hope that you would also
consider that right now there's a very
strong push that's going on
in legislation right now for house bill
20 which
will substantially impact again monies
that are going to be coming into the
adequacy a polls not only at the local
level but at the state level
you know as you start to look at these
numbers of home schoolers we're all 226
of our homeschooling students um to take
the 5 000
that is offered to them through that
opportunity that's being presented in hb
we're looking at a loss of oh somewhere
in the order of 1.13 million dollars
from kearsarge alone which is not a
large school district
to the adequacy pool that local number
by the way
as you start to play around with a
little bit is is
substantial for us let's just leave it
at that so you're not just talking about
necessarily
stabilizing our budget moving forward
you're also stabilizing our budget in
the potential face of a massive
loss of adequacy funds to the state
coffers and
substantial increases to the local
property tax so
if i can answer any questions i'd be
happy to do so
thank you assistant returning any
questions from the committee
seeing none appreciate your testimony
and some detail thank you
you make sure that weiler i think
representative umberger and
representative heath have their hands
just thank you all right who was first
we'll go to representative heath this
time
thank you mr chair um and and thank you
mickey for noticing me
i just want to ask a question in
regard with regard to the need to move
this through if possible legislatively
in a rapid fashion um could you
i'm sorry is the question of me uh
representative heath i apologize
yes it is um just um in terms of your
budget
knowing that these funds would be
available
in what timeline would be the best for
you
obviously as expeditiously as possible
um you know as we face all these
these these concerns that are coming up
with covid right now we've expended
just about every single dollar that's
come to us from the federal government
for the purpose of
creating safe conditions within the
schools so every dollar lost
is representative of the existing budget
that we had already proposed
so it's not like we can turn around and
say that we're going to share these
investor dollars and other dollars you
know to offset um
offset costs that are associated with
students moving in and out
i think it's also important to realize
that delay that you're looking at right
there you know is a year out
and so if those students are coming back
you're kind of seeing a two
a twofold hit for us and and i've tried
to explain this to people before and
they don't really understand this that
that when students come back and forth
from homeschooling environments the
inconsistencies that are related with
their educational experience create
substantial difficulties for school
districts
who are trying to align their
educational experiences
with state curriculum state mandated
curricular around competency development
etc
so what happens is you get a twofold
increase you get them back so you have
to actually service their needs without
those adequacy funds in place for them
but you also have additional associated
costs because we have to recover those
students
and bring them back up to the standards
of competency that the state requires
so and believe me when i tell you this
the majority of the experiences i've
worked as a school principal
for 15 years prior to my being an
assistant superintendent for the last
four
in every circumstance that i've ever
been in in four districts from the state
of new hampshire
um some in the southern tier some up
here uh in here in southwestern's
every single time that i've encountered
this homeschooling equation it's always
the same
there is a substantial portion of that
return that costs us
huge amounts of resource times to
recover those students because they just
don't get
the consistent instructional experience
that we would expect of them under the
state standards
thank thank you thank you
yeah mike thank you very much for uh for
coming in
my question is uh are the uh
school districts required to
provide the uh number of homeschoolers
to the uh the state that
i guess i should say the new
homeschoolers to the
state so uh in answer to that um
representative hamburger i i don't
believe that they're required to
represent the the new students they're
required to represent the total students
through the adma
numbers that are uh requested of us or
demanded of us i should say
uh in october october 1st um and so that
sets the values
and i think that's the that's the nature
of this game is that it's
it's a year out in which you you realize
those funds
and so this is going to impact us but
it's going to be well over a year down
the road
in that respect if i might follow up
follow up so if we
took the homeschool figure from
2020 and
uh subtracted that out from the total
homeschoolers that we have in
2021 that would give us some sort of
idea as to the
number of students that might in fact
come back
to the school when you meet
it it's a difficult prospect because i
think every district faces different
numbers in different ways and i'll give
you another example that's been talked
about regionally
so we've seen a a number of students
since october who've moved in
to our school district to take advantage
of fall and
summer housing uh on in lake properties
um you know we had uh i looked at my
numbers earlier today about 26 students
move into the district after october
first and we know for a fact that
they're living in communities
that were summer homes because what
happens is
under covet is is that communities in
manchester who have you know residents
there who have summer homes
are moving here because of the stability
of our educational system
and the low numbers relative to covid in
comparison with their homes
um where they normally reside and many
of those are now indicating to us that
they want to stay great we're doing a
hell of a job excuse my
conversation but but you know it does
have a real impact on us because all of
those
numbers are after the edm numbers have
been already figured out
so i don't know the exact way to express
that to
representative von berger as to how to
give you the most stable numbers
but i can tell you this if you do look
at those comparisons you are going to
see
students who are returning to our fold
who are either going to be students who
are going to be move-ins to our
community because of our stability
or returning home school students and
frankly we need those funds
thank you very much any further
questions
seeing none thank you mr bessette thank
you
and nancy or mick do we have anybody
else waiting to testify
i see no additional hands raised thank
you very much
uh representative petry since uh when
you first took the attendance
enter into the discussions and come in
and attend like
uh representative edwards will any any
other people you can add to the
attendance list that
weren't here at the first call
representative the verge came in at 9
30.
everything edwards came in at about 9
20.
uh representative hatch
at 9 10. that's all mr chairman
very thorough thank you very much
appreciate you all attending
as i said i'll plan to do the exec a
week from
uh today at ten o'clock uh we'll do a
zoom session again
uh since it'll be a fairly short meeting
it isn't worth
making a trek if we're gonna have a
quick meeting
um so we'll have to do that because i
i failed to put executive session may
follow
so we'll deal with that next week and
it'll be a warm-up for hearing the uh
the governor's
peace and the governor's and i know that
some of you
division chairs are already uh hearing
from some of your departments that
you'll be dealing with
uh representative walnut you had a
question
um yes thank you chairman
wyler i was wondering are you going to
read
into the record the uh people who've
signed in
in support and against the piece of
legislation we just heard
um i will tell you this there's 237
that signed in and support eight that
are just
zero neutral uh six wishing to testify
and we've added another one to that
uh does the committee wish me to read
the 237
or it'd be about 230 now
you want to hear them all no
could i would it
is it we'll put it in the folder how can
committee members find that information
the house the house website has new
facilities for signing up
and for seeing so you can see much of
so we could see i'm sorry another one
more question
it's possible for us to see all of those
people who signed in on this bill
can anybody from lba confirm that
i don't know the answer to that but i
can connect with ann fitzgerald to see
what the other committees have been
doing to this point
um as far as making the uh
sign up sheets available to the public
or to the members
i'm not sure if they've already been
putting him online but i can connect
with her
we do have access to a document that is
updated periodically so after this
meeting be happy to forward
the latest one that we've received if
that would be helpful for the members
representative weiler you're muted sorry
uh
i i can i can forward all the lists that
i got
everybody on the committee and then
you'll all see
uh who signed up and so on so i can
i'll try to forward those to the full
committee
anybody in there you'll click on the
attachment
for each bill and see
who signed up those are the same ones i
have before me and normally
they don't come to the whole committee
they come to the chair so
i'll make sure you can all see those and
anybody that's interested can
download them and look at them so thank
you for pointing that out i didn't
realize that
you know i didn't i didn't think you
wanted to take the time for me to read
237 names so representative weiler i
have my hand up i don't think you can
see it
ah sorry about that no that's all right
uh
i you know from my perspective i i would
be
hoping that there'd be a more systemic
way of handling the sign-in sheets
rather than uh the workaround of having
the committee chairs email each
bill's lists out it it seems like
representative walner's brought a a good
point and it'd be
nice if there was um just a smooth
systematic way to have those available
to the public and the committee that
would be my request
well normally the blue sheet isn't isn't
made public if it's very extensive
there's page after page of it
um you know sometimes they don't even
count them up with the computer counting
them up for me
so uh but i will i will send all those
those forms out that i got that you can
see
uh the people that signed up and and how
much
how many uh gave how many minutes they
were going to speak and so on
so yes that's a public thing there's no
reason you should all have it
should no reason you shouldn't all have
it so
i will do that and as i said i will
talk to janet and put in the uh a
request that we have a
exec session a week from today ten
o'clock
tuesday morning anything else for the
good of the order
anybody else i'm i'm pleased to see you
all you're looking well
um and uh
we're missing a few people but we had a
quorum so
i'm delighted in that representative
representative
representative heath had her hand up at
one point i'm sorry
representative i'm okay thank you mr
chair i'm all set my question was
answered
okay very good all right so
if there's nothing else we will adjourn
this meeting until next week
i thank you all for your attendance
thank you